Dean, welcome. Yo, Gold Logic. How you
been? Been pretty good. How about
yourself? Yeah, good. Good. Yes, so is
there like a particular topic of
discussion here or Yep. It's why do you
dislike Paul? I'll go back to what other
brother was saying. He contradicts what
the apostles taught. This is like
historically taught that um if you look
at the historicity of the earliest
Christians, they didn't believe Jesus to
be deified and this was like a later
development and it's proven that like
Paul did have some form of deified
conception of Jesus to at least some
extent.
>> I got you. So, whoever goes against the
teachings of the apostles, then you're a
false messenger? Yeah, so any
theological uh distinctions, you'll be
seen as someone that's deviating from
the doctrines that Jesus taught.
>> All right. Where do you get the
teachings of the apostles? Yeah, sure.
So, we can look at it from like
historical secular perspective or you
can look at it from the Islamic
perspective. From the historical Islamic
perspective, sorry, the historical
secular perspective does actually align
with the Islamic one in the conception
that the earliest Christians were all
Jews. They believed in one God. They
believed
>> Where do the secular scholars get the
teachings of the apostles? Yeah, these
these multiple sources. They would do
like textual criticism on on the Bible.
So, the Bible would be one of their
sources, but they wouldn't be taking it
wholesale because obviously they they
would be saying they would be critiquing
the reliability of the sources cuz No,
they say that this is what they believed
and taught. They used the Bible and you
admitted it that So, so the scholars but
the scholars don't take it wholesale.
Wait a second. You yourself admitted
that one of their sources that they
glean from to get the teachings of the
apostles is in the Bible. So, when we
look at the teachings of the apostles
that we find in the Bible, you're saying
that Paul contradicts them? Yeah, from
the historical from the historical
actual conception of what the disciples
taught, that would be contradicting what
Paul taught. Now, to get an
understanding of what the disciples
taught, the scholars that I mentioned
aren't going to be taking uh the Bible
wholesale. That's like the composition
fallacy.
>> take the Bible to understand what the
apostles taught? Just just let me to
finish. Yeah, they do take parts of the
Bible there, but they don't take whole
wholesale as I said.
>> Bible No, they take the Bible to know
what Jesus to what the apostles taught
and believed about Jesus.
>> a composition fallacy. They don't take
the entirety of the Bible.
>> Do Do they All right, for example, do
the secular historians or the historical
scholars conclude that the apostles
believed that Jesus died by crucifixion
and rose again on the third day and that
they thought that they
>> No. No, rising the secular historians
would not believe that. Yes, they do.
They would believe that's a historical
This idea that Wait Wait Wait, so just
just to be clear. You're saying that the
secular scholars, non-Christian
scholars, do not agree that the apostles
believed that they saw a resurrected
Christ?
Yeah, that's true. Okay, what does Bart
Ehrman say on this issue? He's a secular
>> Ehrman
Yeah, he's a secular historian. He he he
would be saying that early Christians
did believe in the resurrection, but it
wouldn't be the apostles. He'd be saying
it would possibly be Paul believing in
this as well as the writers of the
Gospels.
>> said No, he says the disciples of Jesus
believed that they saw a resurrected
Christ. This is what This is one of the
facts that they all agree on. No. Paul,
I think certainly had a vision of Jesus.
He he he thought By vision, I don't mean
any I don't mean it's a hallucination. I
mean he saw something. Either it was a
hallucination, in other words, the thing
wasn't there, or it really was Jesus.
But either way, he saw something. And
some of the earlier disciples did, too.
That's why they believed in the
resurrection. They they believed because
they had they saw Jesus. And I think
they absolutely Some of them absolutely
saw I doubt if all 12 11 did, but I but
I my guess is a couple of them did.
Maybe Peter, maybe Mary Magdalene.
They're the ones who were first credited
with seeing Jesus. And so, I think they
had some kind of visionary experience
and Christians would say, "Well, they
saw Jesus. He appeared." And
non-Christians would say, "Well, they
had hallucinations." But either way, I
think they saw something that convinced
them that Jesus was raised. Yes. I I I
agree with All right, so who who is so
who's somebody who's a reputable
historian, a reputable
>> Yeah, Bart Ehrman. Yeah, yeah. So, so
Bart Ehrman talks about He talks about
this uh he debates other scholars on
this on this topic.
>> So, so who's a who's a reputable
historian? Give me a reputable historian
who says that the disciples did not
think that they saw a risen Christ.
Yeah, Bart Ehrman. They they believed
because they had they saw Jesus. Can you
bring it up, please? Yeah, I mean you're
just going to have to give me a sec. You
don't take your time. In the meantime,
we can just continue the discussion. I
want to talk about the epistemics of
>> You're you're you're building you're
building your stuff on a false premise
here. You're trying to say now that
there are secular scholars that say the
secular reputable historians, New
Testament historians, who say that the
disciples did not think that Jesus rose.
Who says that? Bart Ehrman says. I need
it.
>> Okay, just give me a couple minutes.
So, it seems like from what he's saying
on his blog,
um the disciples didn't witness his
resurrection, but this idea came to the
disciples and from his perspective, they
came to believe this from an early band
of followers that Jesus had. So, it's
not My claim would just be that they
didn't they didn't witness it.
>> They they believed because they had they
saw Jesus. But from his perspective,
they came to believe in it, but I just
dispute the historicity of the people
who who claim to have witnessed it.
>> Oh. Hold on a second now. So, it's not
Bart Ehrman that says that they didn't
find or didn't believe that they saw a
risen Christ. They did believe it. The
earliest followers of Jesus believed
that they saw a risen Christ. They had
an experience. Come on, man. Yeah, so as
I mentioned, he does he says that they
believed in the resurrection through
other testimonies, but there's no
there's no evidence that the disciples
themselves saw him rise.
>> that's not what he says there. They they
believed because they had they saw
Jesus. How do you know he said Do you
have it in front of you? No, can you can
you Let's let's uh pull it up, please.
Can you put it put the link in here so
we can all look at it? And let's let's
read it together to see what you're
leaving out. So, this is from our Bart
Ehrman's blog, right? The most important
result of the disciples' belief that God
had raised Jesus from the dead was that
it radically changed their understanding
of what it meant to say Jesus was the
Messiah. So, the disciples believed that
Jesus was raised from the dead according
to Bart Ehrman, right? Yeah, so if you
just got to keep reading, then we can
gain an understanding. Of course. So,
the disciples believed that Jesus was
raised from the dead. Nice. As I have
explained before that in my view, Jesus
did believe he was the Messiah da da da
da.
Given everything we know Jews believe
woo woo woo woo woo.
>> What are you doing? Go read it.
>> [laughter]
>> But that's not I It's not It's there.
>> No, that's fine. That's fine. I'll I'll
read it. I'll read it. Okay. I'll I'll
No, I'll I'll continue, but it's Yeah,
I'll instead of blah blah blah, I'll
just
>> So, Jesus I'm
Just relax. I like I like to read what's
relevant, but if you want to I don't I
don't mind this. Okay. So,
while you take your time, I'll take my
>> that in my view, Jesus did believe he
was the Messiah and his followers
believed it. Given everything we know
about Jewish beliefs at that time, that
almost certainly means that almost
certainly mean that they thought that he
was the king of the Jewish people.
That's certainly how the Roman governor
Pontius Pilate took it. It was because
Jesus made such a claim that Pilate
ordered him crucified. The crucifixion
would have proved beyond any doubt to
any to anyone paying attention that
Jesus was not the Messiah after all. By
the way, so did it According to Bart
Ehrman, did the disciples believe that
Jesus was crucified?
Uh yeah, they did. Okay, so they
believed that Jesus was crucified and
they believed that God raised him from
the dead. Interesting.
>> Yeah, so remember and according to what
you said,
you got to wait 1 second. Wait, can I
According to what you said, let me just
land this and I'll let you go. You can't
just ask me Yes or no then let me
explain. Well, I I asked I I asked it
for a reason. It's fine. It's fine.
Let me explain. I
asked it for a reason. If you're just
going to read I asked it for a reason.
So, you're just going to So, now I got
to mute you. So, be quiet. Control
yourself. I asked it for a reason. So,
your stance was that whatever doesn't go
with historically the secular historical
view of what the disciples believed and
taught, then that that means that that
person would be a false messenger.
According to the secular historians,
well, one of them at least, they say
clearly that the disciples believed that
Jesus was crucified and they believed
that Jesus rose again on the third that
that Jesus rose from the dead. So, by
your standard, Muhammad's already out.
Paul's in right now. But let's let's
keep reading.
>> yeah, okay. So, so let me to respond to
that if you're going to make a claim. Go
ahead.
Yeah, so the idea of Jesus being
crucified, that's fine. There there's no
problem believing that. And if If the
disciples did If the disciples did come
to believe that the the way that Jesus,
peace be upon him, was not killed or
that he he did actually um manage to
survive the crucifixion. If they did
believe that for some reason he was
resurrected, that has no bearing
[clears throat] on him being deified. It
has no bearing on the Trinity. It has no
bearing on all all of these doctrines
that developed later on. So, even if
even if
>> It has every bearing on Islam. Even if
we're Even Even if a Muslim were to take
this historical perspective, the
disciples later on took that these
testimonies of Jesus being resurrected,
then he was risen. There's no
incompatibility with Islam. But go
ahead.
>> That's a that's an incompatibility with
Islam. To believe that To believe that
Jesus To believe and teach that Jesus
died by crucifixion goes against Islam
according to our last conversation with
you because he didn't. You said that he
didn't die. It was made to appear so.
And not to them. They You said that they
followed conjecture of liars. If they're
going around believing this and
spreading this this spreading this lie
and this deceit, that directly goes
against Islam. Yeah, it's a different
Yeah. You said the disciples to go
against them, what they taught and
believed, you said to go against them is
would make you a false messenger. That's
what you said.
>> Yeah, in terms of In terms of
theological for going against the
crucifixion of Jesus, which the
disciples believed. Yeah, in terms of
theological In terms of theological
That's That's theological. Yeah, one
sec. One second. One second. Anything
that Jesus taught the disciples that was
theological in nature and they
transmitted to us, that is going to be
co-aligned within Islam. These aren't
being transmitted by Jesus. These are
being transmitted by the Jews by
by other Wait, let Let let me just
finish. So, any theological beliefs that
the disciples had learned from Jesus and
they transmitted is going to be aligned
with within Islam.
As I just just let me finish if you
don't mind. So, when yeah, the disciples
yeah, the disciples within the chain of
transmission of theological beliefs that
they're getting from Jesus.
>> This is theological. This is
theological. What are you talking about?
What are you what are you waffling
about?
You can't just interrupt and say and
make a point. Wait for me to finish,
then maybe your
Maybe your question will have an answer.
Just just let me finish. You don't have
an answer. Yeah, things Things that are
theological in nature Things that are
theological in nature that the disciples
might have believed coming from other
sources such as Jesus being crucified or
such as Jesus being resurrected if they
did believe in these things and they did
teach these things, they're not going to
be held accountable cuz they didn't know
that the true beliefs is that Jesus
wasn't resurrected or that Jesus wasn't
Hold on, ladies and gentlemen. They
won't be held accountable because they
didn't know. Forget the deceit that
Allah that Allah left out. They would
they didn't know, so they won't be held
accountable for going around preaching
that Jesus was crucified and then also
the theological belief that Jesus rose
again from the dead, which you said that
if you go against what the disciples
taught, then you're a false messenger.
My God.
>> The disciples The disciples I'm Hold on.
Hold on, Dean.
Hold on, Dean. Hold on, Dean. Hold on,
Dean. Hold on, Dean. Hold on, Dean. Hold
on, Dean. Hold on, Dean. Hold on, Dean.
Hold on, Dean. from Jesus himself. Hold
on, Dean. Let's keep reading because now
we're discovering your lie about what
you said about Bart Ehrman. So, it says
here, "The crucifixion would have proved
beyond a doubt that to anyone paying
attention that he wasn't the Messiah
after all. Rather than overcoming the
enemy to establish a
a new kingdom, he was he was squashed by
the enemy, publicly humiliated, and
tortured to death. That was the opposite
of what would happen with the Messiah.
But then something equally dramatic
happened. The disciples came to believe
that Jesus was raised from the dead.
working out the implications of that
belief for understanding Jesus and it
led over a long series of reflections
among a number of Jesus growing band of
followers to rather amazing conclusions.
It is in fact the beginning of the idea
of a trinity." Dean,
you literally said that the belief in
the burial in the death of Jesus Christ
and his resurrection did not lead to
these theological uh mishaps that that's
incompatible with the Quran. That has no
bearing on him being deified. Has no
bearing on the trinity.
>> When Bart Ehrman here says that the
belief the disciples believe, by the
way, the disciples believing that Jesus
uh was raised again from the dead is the
beginning of the idea of a trinity.
Yeah. Okay, so I want you I want you to
go back to the to the beginning just a
bit before that. Yeah, just up there.
And if you don't mind, just don't Now,
just a bit down. A bit down. I want to
include the bottom section as well. "The
crucifixion would have proved beyond any
doubt to anyone paying attention that
Jesus was not the Messiah after all."
So,
the disciples would have had this
conception, "Okay, we need to reconcile
this with the fact that we do believe
Jesus is the Messiah." Now, they don't
have any form of divine revelation given
to them. So,
yeah, this idea that the Messiah would
be killed contradicts the idea of
Messiahship. But then something equally
dramatic happened. So, after the
crucifixion of Jesus, the disciples came
to believe that he was raised from the
dead. They started working out the
implications of that belief for
understanding Jesus. And where did they
get this from? They got this from a
growing band of followers from other
people that claimed they saw Jesus
resurrected. Now, let me finish finish
I'll I'll let you finish I'll let you
finish I'll
I'll let you finish I
I still have other things to address.
You have to let me You have to let me
finish.
>> stop. Does it say
that they got it from a growing band of
followers? Does he say that?
Does he say that Does he believe that
that the disciples witnessed him
resurrect?
>> They they believed because they had they
saw Jesus. Dean, you're you're about 5
seconds from from just getting out of
here because you're such a liar, bro.
Stop doing this to yourself. You was
just reading it verbatim. You wasn't
given any commentary. You were reading
it verbatim. Why did you add in that
they got this from a growing band of
followers?
>> Read it right here. They started Read it
right there. They started working out
the implications of that belief for
understanding Jesus. This was the
disciples after Jesus was crucified. And
it led over a long series of reflections
among a number of Jesus grow growing
band of followers to amazing
conclusions. The from an early from from
the disciples and these early ground
growing band of followers, they they
came to these amazing conclusions after
the crucifixion. Yes, after they
believed what?
After they had believed that Jesus died
by getting these testimonies from other
than Jesus Well, no. Wait, wait, wait.
Where does it say that they got a
testimony from anyone other than Jesus?
It doesn't say none of that.
Or or or Are you presupposing your
Islamic view here?
Okay, would it be historical to say that
the disciples weren't present at the
time of the crucifixion?
>> No, it wouldn't be historical to say
that. Because according according to the
historical narratives, the disciples
were there. They were watching from a
distance these things. Yes, from
from a distance. Exactly, they ran away
and from a distance uh
a few women saw that someone was being
crucified.
>> Not just the women. It says that all who
knew him and followed him from Galilee
watched these things from a distance.
From a distance. Were they able to Okay,
were they able to make up the fact that
this was Jesus
>> were watch Yeah, they were watching from
a distance. Wait, you mean Where did you
Where did you get this from? Hold on a
second.
>> get this from? From the book of Mark and
Luke, by the way. Okay, Mark and Luke.
Okay, So, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Are
you saying Hold on. Let's get back to
this. Can you at least at least
apologize or say, "You know what? I did
read this into the text that this stuff
It doesn't say that they
believed that Jesus was resurrected
based off something that got something
from non-Jesus, something they didn't
get from Jesus themselves or whatever."
It doesn't say that, right?
Okay, tell me what you understand by
"They started working out the
implications of that belief."
>> that now. And it led Yes, it's implied.
"Over a long series of reflections among
a number of Jesus growing band of
followers" Hey, Dean. Hey, Dean, man.
This is This was fun, bro. Thank Thank
you for this clip. Again, guys, one of
their guys.